"Set, Scene 1 Take 1"
*light hearted music plays*
Mark: Alright.
*various clicks*
*grunt*
*clicks*
*click*
Ethan: I need an end slate.
Ethan: Yaaay.
*CLICK*
*clap*
*clap, clap, clap*
"Uhh, what the hell do I do with my life; Take 1." *clap*
"Take 2." *clap*
(firmly) "Take 3" *clap*
"Take 4"
*various uncertain claps*
background: wow
*incomprehensible*
*pblblblblblblsssh*
EH
*whistle*
Amy: Help.
Kat: Oh your eyeliner looks good!
Mark: "Everyone" Ethan: "Everybodyyy"
Mark: "HUUEAAGHHHHH UGHN" "HUUEAAGHHHHH UGHN"
*background chattering*
*whispers* Ethan
HEY! *stammers* "Get outta here!"
Ethan: "Are you filming mee? " Mark: "Yeah Man" Ethan:"Staaaaahhp  Baaabe!"
"Huohoh, STAHP*giggle*"
*menacing laugh*
*grunts and evil laughing* *beeping*
Mark: *grunting* "You idiot just press X!"
"Yaaassss!"
*whispered* wh..whats happening..?
*inhalation of pain*
*scream of agony*
*PFFFFHHHHHHHHTTT*
Mark: "WhOA HOLY SHIT!"
Mark: "Thank you so much for coming out, oh!  Thank you..  Bonjour! *stammers* Bonsoir!"
Mark: "And bonjour to you "
Mark: "I- I feel like we've met before you look so familiar.. gh- oh! Hey! Oh.. mmsh this is delicious!  Thank you! Mmmm, yes!"
Mark: "You didn't eat any of yours, that's okay.. I'll eat enough for the both of us "
Mark: "I just want- oh! *sniff-sniff* *cough-choke* It's good.. *cough* Thank you.. "
Mark: "Ahhh  but you.. *cough-choke*.. I literally *cough* choked on that lettuce"
*breathes in deeply*
*Coughing*
Pam: Do it again? *background giggles*
Mark: *pained* One second
*laughter*  Mark: I actually choked on it
Pam: Ah chef comes in with the check
Oh, a road!
Hey there's a road over here, we could find it, travel it and maybe find some people..
Oh what's that... SHINY. Oh good, Me likey Shiny!
Shiny good, Shiny is da best!!
You want SHINY or you want ROAD?
Whad'ya want?!?
You go A or B, it's multi choice, you can choose two!
You can do 2 of those, it's 2 choice do that!
Like? Me like too.
Both good option.
That lead to alien, don't tell nobody.
That lead to LA nuke *Laughs*
Yeah....Every Die
I don't know... I just started Flubbing the road
♫♫
*Snapping Begins*
*Tyler Burps*
♫♫
♫ Wink Wonk, look under that cone..what do you see? ♫
Some good old PCP!
♫♫
Mark: There's the exit. Let's go come on!
What are we waiting for?!? Yada Yada
Come on.
You stupid asshole, cmon!
Fucking douche.
Piece of shit.
what're you thinking?
I hate you. Huh?
We'll meet back up...*splutters*
*slight giggles*
Ethan: That will be the transition
Just coming out of your asshole
*Mark giggles*
*laughter in background*
Ethan: OOAAH
*laughter*
Mark: Good idea, you go that way, I'll go this way and maybe we'll tell each other about the exit, okay?
Pam: Oh
*Laughter*
Mark: Hey big boy~
Mark: Hey how's it going
*mark giggles*
Its the BLOOPER ENDING